Gina from Ithaca New York wants to know
if you think you would have a shot with
Courtney if you had maintained your
sobriety
yes do you yeah probably that was Scott
Disick and his ex Kourtney Kardashian
reflecting on their failed relationship
back in 2021. now a source tells E.T
Scott still has regrets about how he
treated Court when they were together so
when you see them together you you feel
like there's a connection there still so
swearing between the two of you on that
couch there does feel like there's no
connection she made that very clear just
now I just want everyone to know
we are just co-parenting no but she's
like you know the only person I've ever
loved in my life so
ET Source explains that Scott is
focusing on moving on accepting his
faults and trying to learn from his
mistakes you dealt with Scott's
substance abuse issues
um and infidelity what was a bigger deal
breaker for you I mean the infidelity
was like I only knew about it at the end
and then so I think the substance abuse
was the
the deal breaker court and Scott split
for good back in 2015 after almost 10
years of dating on and off the two Share
three children together 12 year old
mason 10 year old Penelope and a
seven-year-old Reign and have worked
hard to co-parent together over the
years
I'm really proud of all of them I think
they're doing amazing and I think
everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but my mom and my dad were like
that it took them years but my dad would
come over once a week for family dinners
and would play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share children
with people and that's how it should be
and Courtney has since moved on with
Blink 182 drummer Travis Barker we're
just you know living our best lives the
two said I do in an unofficial Vegas
ceremony back in April you did a
practice run on the wedding
congratulations thank you about 12 30 on
I guess Monday morning I got a call that
a celebrity wanted to get married they
just said a celebrity and we need helps
I guess what happens in Vegas doesn't
always stay in Vegas a month later the
lovebirds made it official tying the
knot in Italy how much do you all love
seeing Courtney this happy oh we all
love it this is her time to shine baby
Courtney met her soul mate that's got to
be hard for Scott to absorb the family
documented the whole thing for their
Hulu series The Kardashians and Scott
was having a hard time accepting the
news that Court moved on she found
someone I'm happy for her she's got a
man that loves her and she deserves it
because
there were so many years that I didn't
put her first now ET sour says Scott
wants to get married one day and start
his next chapter too but that isn't in
the cards for him right now as for his
relationship with the family our source
says they still talk and see each other
all the time adding that it isn't a
toxic situation and they've moved past
any difficulties I mean I think you just
gotta figure out really what's important
to you at the end of the day and all
that Echoes what Court's little sister
Kendall Jenner said on season one of the
family's hit show Scott is is my brother
like we're basically blood at this point
and so it would be very weird if he
wasn't a part of our family and I don't
think there's ever going to be a day
where he's not a part of our family in
some capacity
[Music]
thank you